Jeremy Corbyn has announced plans to
invest an additional 4.8 billion pounds
into England school system by 2022 if
Labour wins the election to fund the
increase the Tories cuts to corporation
tax will be reversed it's only fair that
businesses should be asked to contribute
to the plan by financing the steps that
we are setting out today and we will do
this by reversing the tax cuts made by
the Conservatives and still keep UK
rates of corporation tax at the lowest
of the group of 7 most industrialized
countries it's what we term our new
settlement when it comes to small
businesses the backbone of our economy a
Labour government will restore small
profits rates and make only a modest
increase and the owners and the
leadership of larger businesses and
corporations we will slowly raise your
level of corporation tax to 26% by the
end of the next parliament it was 28%
when the coalition government came into
office in 2010 again this is actually
even below the level of the last Labour
government inclusive fair and costed
that's our plan to upgrade our economy
so does increasing corporation tax make
he cannot make sense or Richard Murphy
from tax research UK in City University
in London think so he joins us via Skype
from Ely in Cambridgeshire and Julian
Jessup disagrees he's chief economist at
the Institute of Economic Affairs and
joins us now from our Westminster studio
Richard let me start with you first you
actually don't think labour going far
enough you'd like to see corporation tax
raised even more why three reasons
really first of all this stops tax abuse
very large numbers of companies in the
UK are now formed simply because people
are using them to undermine the income
tax system international insurance
system and pay much lower tax than they
would otherwise pay that makes no sense
at all it cost the country around 4
billion pounds which could be much
better spent and therefore that's the
first advantage the second big one is
that actually this puts us on a level
playing field with other countries and
that's fine
that's where we should be but thirdly it
encourages investment if this new rate
of tax was matched with an increase in
investment allowances to a hundred
percent in the year that a company did
spend money in the UK economy the
subsidy provided to a company invested
would increase from about three pounds
eighty for every 100 pounds spent to 26
pounds for every 100 pounds spent and
that would mean more investment more
growth more productivity wage increases
more taxes paid a spiral upwards which
would not only pay for itself but of
course it would pay for this investment
in education which itself would
massively increase the return to the UK
economy is for the institution to enter
the Institute and fiscal studies are
quite skeptical about that though they
said depends on how the money's invested
but also on this point of cutting
corporation tax 2010 corporation tax was
at 28% and it raised 43 billion pounds
last year when it was only 20% it raised
nearly 50 billion pounds I mean surely
that is proof that cutting corporation
tax is good no it isn't the reason for
the increase is the number of companies
grew and the reason the number of
companies grew is because of the rise in
the gig economy the rise in tax abuse
and the rise in employment insecurity
because people were forced out to stay
with jobs into insecure contracting
that's why more corporation tax was paid
that's not a sign of progress that's a
sign of insecurity of people living in a
precarious lifestyle where corporation
tax had to be paid because that's what
their so-called employers demanded no
there wasn't a real increase in
corporation tax at all that's a myth
Julia Jessup let me bring you in here at
this point I mean what do you think is
the optimum tax raising point for
corporation tax
I actually think probably lower than the
rates that we are currently paying and I
think the key point here is that
companies aren't some sort of magic tree
that you can shake and loads of money
falls out in reality corporation tax is
ultimately paid by ordinary people it's
paid by pensioners who own shares in
companies or it's paid by workers who
might face lower wages if their
companies can't afford to pay their tax
bills it's paid by all of us if the
investment is lower and economic
activity is lower I think a walking
great big increase in tax as the Labour
Party is
would be very damaging to the economy
particularly at a time when most
countries are heading in the opposite
direction somewhat of Murphy's point
though that if you recycle these tax
revenues in education you raise money in
education spending on education you get
a bigger bang for your buck I mean it's
a much evidence that cutting corporation
taxes actually boosts economic growth
well in the long-running increases in
spending on education and maybe even
health could boost the productive
potential of the economy and I think
socially would be a good thing but in
the short run there's no doubt that
massive hikes in corporation tax would
be very damaging as I say most countries
are already moving in the opposite
direction and where we want you to send
a signal to the rest of the world that
Britain is open for business after
brexit I think reversing the corporate
tax increases cuts in the last few years
would be exactly the wrong thing to do i
Richard Murphy that's quite a crucial
point isn't it most other countries are
cutting corporation tax and also this
would be a reversal of 45 years worth of
UK government policy I mean that is not
a good signal to send to businesses when
they want to invest look sometimes you
have to send a radical signal a
conservative Chancellor did that in 1988
it was Nigel Lawson and he he changed
the whole system he made companies pay
tax but he gave them big tax allows us
to encourage them to invest this changed
that Jeremy Corbyn is bringing in would
actually send a signal that Britain
really is open to business and really
does want to encourage those who want to
invest and create jobs in the UK will
get lots of tax relief for doing so
there could be no stronger signal that
people who are serious about working in
this country will get the incentive they
required he's right on this one there's
no economic question otherwise
corporation tax cuts have never
generated growth this targeted increase
matched with high investment allowances
could deliver a lot of new jobs for this
country and what about Julian Jessup's
point this this is not a pain-free way
of raising tax revenue and ultimately
corporation taxes paid by individuals
isn't it either those who hold shares
directly everyone who holds shares in
their pension funds well I don't dispute
that in fact it is by and large out paid
by shareholders there is no real
evidence that it's paid by employees
that's a nonsense let's talk about the
shareholders
we have massive wealth inequality in
this country we may not wish to
recognize that but in fact clearly
that's the case over half the country
has almost no savings at all a tax on
companies does help to reduce inequality
and that is good for this country
because if we redistribute the money
towards those who need it students for
example who can't afford access to
university we not only give them a
chance but we increase their spending
and that's good for growth as well the
wealthiest don'ts then the poorest
people in this country spend all their
income and maybe more and that
stimulates the economy this is another
move which helps us as a result all
right very briefly Julian last word to
you George Osborne tax the banks very
aggressively he put a surcharge on
profits he put on a banking levy but the
banks over taxed in this country
actually no I don't think they are I
think there are plenty of businesses
that have behaved very badly in the last
few years who probably should be paying
more tax but ultimately I don't think
Rich's arguments make sense he can't say
on the one hand but the government can
raise a lot more money from increasing
corporation tax and then say that's
offset in some way by investment
allowances which means giving money back
to companies if the labor does want to
raise a significant amount of money from
corporates then their tax bills do have
to go up